[Musique]
ah les belles dames qui passai rue autre
fois
ah les belles dames font les yeux doux à
d'autres que moi je pomis dans un
patelin entre S l et Paris autrefois
soirée matin c'était le paradis j'aiis
sous tout le dimanche et ses
encombrements je mettais ma chemise
blanche ma class
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ahillerei
ah
les onont les yeux doux à d'autre que
moi
ah mais c'est la
[Musique]
faute ohoui c'est elle qui
me
autrefis a pensé je deviens mélancolique
ce weekend je voyais passé le tout
parisique mais voilà sous ma casquette
j'avais un charm fou lesames coqu les
[Musique]
marreis
ah je le
proclame les maris sont des
rabageois car ils ont préféré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'autout
ah dans mon cœur c'est la band
rout il y a plus que le curé piedb qui
m'amène son solx sinon il y a pas plus
d'auto que du temps du silex j'en ai
pour 20 ans au moins à débiter tout mon
super d'ici là j'en suis certain
j'aurais tout fichu en l'air
et belle dame qui passait par ma rue
autre fois
oui les belles dam dans son tout d'un
grand feu de joie
car je m'en vais faire sauter
[Musique]
l'autoroute oui je le ferai coûe que
cû avec moi car et je m' de sauter
l'autoroute oh oui je ferai coute que
goû car je m' vais faire sauter l'ut
route
oui
[Applaudissements]
ci